batum and george on booker
now george with four to shoot long three
from booker
[Music]
[Applause]
george sidestepped eurosta missed the
layup rebound ayton takes it away from
zubox
[Music]
and booker fouled by patrick beverly
that's going to be four on beverly
as booker is down and there's blood on
beverly's head i don't know
it's coming from devon
[Applause]
beverly trying to say he hit me
shot in the face for booker
can't see where the blood is coming from
on booker it's like right above the nose
control during that we'll check to see
if this foul meets right here
this reaching in on a headbutt
that's not a flavor foul but it is a
foul control
plays under video
he just leaned in and try and get him as
booker makes his move
and you're the phoenix suns hopefully is
just the cut and
the mindset is can we make sure that
devin booker doesn't have to go in the
back to get stitches or anything like
that
i remember years ago steve nash had that
in a big playoff game
yeah against san antonio and it looked
awful
and beverly's got blood on his they call
it by the way a common foul i don't know
if you could hear it at home with
the crowd chanting
[Applause]
beverly sometimes plays on the edge
plays tough but he's just reaching in
there
that's the 14th foul against the
clippers fourth foul on beverly with 3
22 remaining here in the third more
chance of beat la
obviously beverly taking a shot too on
the play
and booker's going to go back to the
locker room
[Applause]
[Music]
so some patch up work certainly to be
done
on devin booker
brooker hasn't shot the ball well you
see the turnovers as well they've done a
good job on them defensively
and where are they going to get offense
right now no campaign on the floor
no booker who's the creator
all right cassini as you can see booker
back out on the floor ran
out to a huge roar from the crowd during
that time out
as luke canard knocks down a three man
quick work done by the medical staff
after that
inadvertent headbutt with patrick
beverly
i'm a big boxing fan i've seen fights
won a loss with
the cut man's ability to make sure a guy
gets back into the ring
it's got a boxers look to it that's for
sure looks familiar
that's the steve nash that was back in
2007 game one of the west semis
suns and spurs first one up winning the
game they couldn't stop the bleeding
that night
in this very arena